our leaders are upping their
expectations of how many people will be
infected in fact saying that 60% of the
American public will be infected with
colonel virus within a year now yeah no
one wants to hear that news but the vast
majority of us are gonna just find dr.
oz talking to ET breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the corona virus how should people be
reacting to the corona virus I know a
lot of folks who are panicked but if you
think about what you can do for yourself
at least you've got a game plan and why
you found that game plan you can move
past the anxiety that's paralyzing a lot
of folks I think the the survival rate
is going to be pretty close to the
traditional fashion flu but when you get
into the older age groups and people
have cardiovascular disease or diabetes
or I just got past cancer have bad lungs
then those folks are really at increased
risk and they're the ones I want to
protect if we can keep them free then
we're gonna have a very low mortality
rate what is your protocol for fighting
clearly there's no cure but fruits and
vegetables help a lot so it might have
been d3 which you get from the Sun as it
gets warmer or take it as a pill form
1,200 units is probably a mainstay
everyone should be taken now that might
actually prevent some virus spread the
other solutions are ones you would take
Ella me if you got sick like vitamin C
and higher doses zinc is pretty
effective we've been using elderberry in
my family for many years and there's
some data support this it's used and
beta glucan which comes from mushrooms
these are pretty straightforward
old-fashioned ideas that work in other
viruses they might be beneficial if you
can track the coronavirus is the virus
really airborne virus is definitely
airborne the virus seems to live on
inanimate objects
this is how you wash your hands like a
surgeon stuff on there like 20 seconds
so over under either the Turkish twist
it's all about the fingertips you dance
you go exercise while you're doing this
I get the thumbs and then get your
fingertips it's like greasing the palm I
don't get this fingernails it should be
short by the way and the other side same
thing
one last clean around and then you're
done oh my putting seconds into it but
you've got most of iris off there do
that sighs Rona right go sink no oh no
biggest to here dry your hands use that
turn off the water use this to protect
you as you get back to a clean
environment and I like the moisturizer
afterwards your hands will get chef
perfect high five just kidding nope
learning watch those hands 20 seconds
none of this none of that and maybe a
little bit more distance you got it
all right and it works
[Music]